ahora vamos a hacer una suma en el
sistema binario sin pasar por el sistema
decimal entonces digamos que tenemos por
aquí este número
y le queremos sumar este otro número
ok queremos hacer esta suma te
recomiendo que le pongas pausa a este
vídeo y trate de hacerlo tú solito el
chiste es simplemente hacer esta suma
tal cual siguiendo el mismo algoritmo
que tenemos en el sistema decimal pero
nunca perdiendo de vista que tenemos
únicamente dos símbolos en el sistema
binario el 0 y el 1
entonces empezamos sumando estos dos
dígitos 1 más 1 es 2 así es que tengo
muchas ganas de colocar aquí un 2 pero
no puedo porque nada más tenemos puros
ceros y unos así es que tenemos que
recordar que el 2 en el sistema decimal
es igual al 10 en el sistema binario
porque tenemos 1 2 y 0 unos de acuerdo
bueno entonces aquí tenemos que poner un
2 pero este 2 tiene dos cifras por lo
que simplemente vamos a poner la primera
cifra por aquí y llevamos la cifra de la
izquierda o sea que vamos a poner un 1
por aquí y continuamos felizmente con
nuestra suma entonces simplemente
tenemos que sumar esto y tenemos aquí 1
2 3
pero el 3 del sistema decimal se escribe
como 11 en el sistema binario ok porque
para escribir 3 tenemos que poner un 2 y
un 1 y entonces regresamos a la suma y
ponemos la cifra de hasta la derecha por
aquí y llevamos todas las cifras de la
izquierda así es que llevamos una y otra
vez volvemos a sumar esta columna
tenemos 1 + 1 2 pero el 2 se escribe
como un 1 y un cero
entonces ponemos el 0 por aquí y
llevamos 1 y 11 son 2 otra vez
así es que ponemos 2 así de fácil ya
terminamos la suma
solo para que me creas que esta suma
está muy bien hecha vamos a verificar la
utilizando el sistema decimal a ver este
número es igual tenemos por aquí un 1
más tenemos también 12 no tenemos ningún
4 pero si tenemos un 8 entonces tenemos
uno más dos más ocho que es igual a 11
pero recuerda que aquí estamos
utilizando ya el sistema decimal decimal
ok cambia este número al sistema decimal
y recuerda que esto lo estamos haciendo
nada más para que veas que realmente
hicimos bien esta suma no tienes que
hacerlo cuando hagas sumas en binario
pero bueno este otro número de aquí en
el sistema decimal aquí tenemos un 1 y
tenemos un 2
y tenemos un 4 así es que este número es
un 7 en el sistema decimal y ahora
veamos este número como se llama en el
sistema decimal a ver este es el lugar
de los hunos y no tenemos ninguno luego
este es el lugar de los dos es así es
que tenemos un 2 no tenemos ningún 4
ningún 8 pero si tenemos un 16 así es
que este número es la suma de 2 más 16
que es igual a 18 en el sistema decimal
decimal entonces ya estamos listos para
verificar si hicimos bien esta suma y
tenemos que 11 + 7 es igual a 18
bueno espero que te diviertas haciendo
estas sumas la verdad antes yo me
divertía un montón